hey guys it's Justine and today we have
Hands-On with a brand new M2 iPad Pro I
know I can't believe it I just feel like
the iPad M1 Pro just came out and I've
used that thing so much this year for
whatever reason earlier this year I
decided to start drawing a lot and I got
super into procreate I did a ton of
illustrations and I was having so much
fun so I really got this all new
appreciation for the iPad and using the
iPad Pro because it is such a high-end
device I never had to worry about
performance at all one of the things I
cannot wait to come to the new M2 iPad
is DaVinci Resolve now I was actually
really surprised to hear that da Vinci
was coming to the iPad before final cut
because that is something that all of us
have just patiently maybe not so
patiently have been waiting for that to
come to the iPad I mean I'm honestly
just waiting for iMovie to be able to
edit vertical video like that's small
simple request but in the meantime
there's other apps like lumafusion which
is one of my favorite editing apps on
the iPad currently DaVinci isn't out yet
so I won't be be able to demo that but I
will show you guys lumafusion which is
one of my favorite editing apps on the
iPad and it's super fun super intuitive
and it really does take advantage of not
only the touch base environment but you
could also use a mouse and keyboard
using shortcut keys and it's pretty
incredible so with the new M2 Chip this
will be giving the iPad an increased 15
faster CPU 35 faster graphics and 50
more memory bandwidth all while
maintaining the 10 hour battery life
another new feature is apple pencil
hover now I haven't tried this yet so I
think that's going to be kind of the
first thing that I'm going to try
there's still more that I want to tell
you about but since I haven't tried this
yet let's just test it out before we get
into more so right here it's not
touching not touching not touching oh
like that's far that is a very far hover
and as I get closer the icon gets a
little bit bigger this is something that
I never really thought that I would want
but this is gonna be great for
illustrating because you're able to
choose brush sizes you're able to see if
the color will match with the other
color and how they will mesh so I'm
super excited excited to try this out in
procreate so on this 12.9 inch iPad it
has an immersive liquid Retina xdr
Display with extreme dynamic range with
up to 1600 nits of peak brightness
another cool thing is it can actually
also be used as a display for reference
color let's check out some of the apps I
have a few things installed here I've
got Adobe Fresco Photoshop and Lightroom
so I'm going to test out Adobe Fresco
I've actually only used this on a PC I
know I'm shook but I've actually got a
few photos here already look at the
hover
I'm not touching but I like this because
I can actually see okay that's the
smudge brush that's the Eraser Vector
brush I'm into Vector let's do that
so there's Adobe Fresco looks great how
about some photoshop okay let's see what
we can open up and this is something
that's new not only in the iPad OS 16
but also in iOS 16. let's go into our
images so when you press and hold
look at that there it is go into
procreate because I know this will work
there it goes and we just imported our
image look at that oh my gosh I love the
hover so much what a great feature super
hyped to start using that now check that
out look at this beautiful work of art
that I just made the fact that this cuts
out so well is super impressive
looks great so now in Photoshop let's
see here we're gonna open up a thumbnail
this is my podcast thumbnail so this is
great so you can see I've got all of my
layers on here giving me a tutorial I
probably should read the tutorial
because I really have not used photoshop
on the iPad before but I use Photoshop
all the time it's like my go-to the
hover once again I mean everything is
working super seamless look at that it's
gonna move us around wow it's actually
quite nice using the apple pencil in
Photoshop all right what else do we have
shape or 3D
I've actually never used this uh let's
set it up what device do you want to use
for modeling we're going to use an apple
pencil let's learn the basics oh we're
actually this is a tutorial this is a
full-on tutorial it's fast super
responsive
shut up that's fun
you've been holding your apple pencil
with your left hand do you want to swap
the UI to the other side that's so
considerate that they knew they knew me
[Music]
great look at that cut out some material
now obviously the iPad is made for
either consuming content or editing
content but you can actually create
content on this as well this does have
two cameras on the back and one on the
front and you can actually shoot 4K
prores content on this iPad so there's a
12 megapixel wide and a 10 megapixel
Ultra ride plus this does have a true
tone Flash and like I said this does
have the lidar right here on the back
near the cameras now much like the
previous iPad this does have support for
Thunderbolt 3 and usb4 and this will
give you access to high performance
external storage docks 10 gigabit
Ethernet connections and one thing
that's pretty great is you can also
connect it to an external display up to
6K resolution one thing I've been super
excited to test out in here is stage
manager because that's something that is
in the Pro Models in iPad OS 16. so you
do have to enable it so when you swipe
down you have this little icon right
here so when you click that this will
allow you to turn on stage manager and
as I open up something else this is
going to be giving you a more windowed
view so it kind of almost feels more
desktop Mac like than an iPad also has
anybody listen to the new Taylor Swift
album streaming everywhere now also
there's an entire Apple Fitness class
dedicated to midnight so super excited
to start taking some of those classes
now here's the stage manager you've got
all of your items over here you can
click through so basically just gives
you like another Dock dock on the side
dock on the bottom so another cool thing
you can do is you can kind of double up
with apps so if I click up here I can
add another window so you're able to add
another window that's already open so
let's add my procreate here so you can
see that I have this now side by side
with my Apple music you can make this
smaller you can make this larger it's
more Mac OS than iPad if you ask me so
you can also full screen back into
whatever app it is that you want and
then it will activate again whenever you
open something else up this is also a
pretty big deal in iOS 16 is there's now
a weather app I know seems like
something that should have been there
from day one but we now have a weather
app so it looks like it's raining in
Redmond Cupertino
partly cloudy also I don't know if I
like this because this is just making me
anxious it's showing all of my devices
that need charged my other iPad is at 55
my airpods Pro are 100 but the case 17
another cool app is filmic pro I really
like this app because this is one of the
apps that a lot of people do use to do
more high-end filmmaking basically lets
you go in and edit every setting
manually which is super exciting now you
may also have noticed that there are
some other iPads that have also came out
at the same time as this new M2 Pro and
that's just the regular iPad which comes
in four different colors you've got a
pink a blue a yellow and a silver now
the main big difference is of course
this does not have an M2 Chip in it it
does have the A14 bionic chip the M2
supports Thunderbolt and USB C4 and one
of the other new features like the
landscape camera placement which is one
of my favorite features did not carry
over to the pros and I'm so sad about it
they now have landscape so when you're
doing conference reference calls the
camera is placed right up here as it
should be but on the pro it is still
placed in the landscape position now
kind of makes sense why they didn't do
this because this really isn't a huge
massive upgrade from the M1 version so
to completely reconfigure this to have a
landscape camera even though it makes
sense the eye is still I'm very sad
because that was one of the features
that I really really was looking forward
to I do have a feeling though I think
that the next iPad Pro will definitely
have it if you want to learn more about
the iPad and the landscape I do have a
full video going over some of the new
details on this one so feel free to
check that out I'll put a link in the
description the other big difference is
the apple pencil 2 does not work with
the new iPad so one of the big benefits
to getting the pro is you will be
getting the new Apple pencil 2 support
and this also does have a weird kind of
charging connecting configurability
because you have to use a USBC cable and
a dongle to connect to the apple pencil
one I mean obviously it's pretty
intuitive I will say it is better than
having this stick out of the side of
your iPad like you had to do before so
you just plug it into the dongle and
then you plug this into your iPad using
USBC I'm definitely glad they did decide
to use USBC on this iPad because that
does allow you to transfer data faster
but the downside is this is what you're
gonna have to do which is why I'm a
really big fan of the apple pencil 2
because it does have gesture control and
now you can actually change inside of
the settings what you want those gesture
actions to be so it definitely makes
things a lot more smooth when you are
doing different tasks it is also a nice
added benefit that this is a matte
pencil it's not super shiny like the
apple pencil one I also like that it has
a flat Edge which is where you
magnetically connect and charge but I
feel like that kind of helps me
orientate my pencil and draw a little
bit easier so I definitely do prefer the
apple pencil too so as you can see I do
have this on the magic keyboard and this
is an added accessory and it is pretty
expensive but it does kind of change the
way that you use your iPad now one of
the things that is new in the other iPad
that I just showed you is this has the
new Smart Keyboard folio and what I
actually really like about the Smart
Keyboard folio is how this folds down it
gives you a much more firm placement of
the display whereas this one yes you can
do this it's free floating it looks
really cool but when you are drawing or
something it has a little bit of Bounce
but that's on the other hand
look at that nice touch ID you know it
doesn't have Touch ID
iPad Pro I know yeah look at this like I
feel
so much better about like pressing into
this display so I feel like this is a
really great example of kind of what the
route is that they're gonna go I think
for the next keyboard because this is
perfect like I can actually draw like
this no problem at all
it works but you can't be as precise the
other upside to the pros is it does have
a pro motion display it also supports
extreme HDR so you really can see the
difference when you are actually editing
or watching content and especially the
promotion when you're sliding through
it's so much smoother I also really like
that you can connect any controller to
this Xbox PlayStation Nintendo switch
and actually be able to play games so
this iPad will be really great for
gaming you can definitely take advantage
of the increased performance with the M2
Chip and of course the extreme dynamic
range that this iPad delivers so you
will get about the same battery life you
get about 10 hours and this is connected
to the magic keyboard I know I've talked
so much about this but I really really
love it so this does have the
pass-through USBC charging which will
free up this other Port I love being
able to connect one of my external
Thunderbolt drives to this and be able
to get all of my files I can start doing
rough edits in lumafusion so the
starting price for these iPads the 11
inch is 7.99 and the 12.9 inch is
actually 10.99 now you can choose
between Wi-Fi or cellular and you can
get in two colors the silver and the
graphite as for storage capacity you can
configure this from 128 all the way up
to two terabytes this is the one
terabyte version in my M1 iPad was also
one terabyte and I still haven't
actually filled that entirely up but I
was using it for a lot of file storage
so if you are actually going to be
editing and storing files on here I
definitely would recommend getting
something at least in the 512 range if
you are going to be actually wanting to
put files on here because these things
fill up very very quickly so that was
just the first look at the new M2 iPad
Pro definitely very excited about this
now it really isn't that huge of an
upgrade from the M1 but this will
definitely give you a boost in
performance and especially if you don't
already have an M1 this can be a huge
upgrade for a lot of people well thank
you guys so much for watching I would
love to hear from you in the comments
below is there anything else that you
would like me to test out here with the
new iPad Pro if you haven't already
please like this video leave me some
comments and be sure to hit the
Subscribe button and don't forget to hit
the Bell as well so you'll be notified
when I post new videos and with that my
friends I will see you in the next video
and if you haven't seen it already be
sure to check out my unboxing of all of
the iPads and also an overview of the
new colored iPads that just came out
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]